I'm going to apologize in advance
because what I'm about to start is kind
of at least at this point kind of theory
heavy
I hate parts of lessons or parts of the
course that are Theory heavy because
that is a practical subject started
doing right well at certain points I'm
going to justify this intersection at
certain point theory is appropriate and
it's the only way for example for a long
time in your life when you think your
trigonometry do you think of these guys
right which makes sense trigonometry is
about triangles and measuring them and
particularly writing triangles but you
guys have already gotten to that point
where math definition for side cause
intent just don't cut it anymore so we
replaced our definitions for
trigonometric functions for here after
here right we say okay stop thinking out
triangles out stop thinking about them
think about that because think about the
unit circle and think about the
coordinates of all those points on the
circumference of the unit circle those
around you definitions for cos inside
the XY coordinate and then everything
else plot is from there right why do we
do this why was it valuable to movie for
heating here not a rhetorical question
sitting here so so the most obvious
reason is when you're in a right angle
triangle you are stuck you're cornered
into the first quadrant right all your
angles in here they've died and these
guys they're all cute right and it's
even worse than that you can't get to
zero or nice even like you have to be
above the ER and you have to be less
than 90 but as soon as you break out of
a triangle and look at the unit circle
now you can get out of it you can have
what we call them angles all and you're
80 magnets she's very good and then
there are lots of other things that are
continuing to flow from that as we go
further through the course you know what
we're going to have a look at as a
result is sort of like this right you
then sign a present and when I talked
about this you've met the functions that
we're going to talk about in this topic
but what need to do is reel back a
little bit and change the way we look at
these functions for a little while
because your current like this baby of
these things is not enough to take you
work particularly into calculus that's
what we're setting the table for okay so
real functions is the head of your
various types of extend this lines its
heading really long because real
functions just means it's shorthand for
function of real numbers
now I alluded to this before just at the
beginning of last period that makes the
question well what about me okay what
comes to this little bit I'm going to
just say a couple of things about real
numbers firstly all the numbers you've
ever dealt with our real numbers
counting numbers negative numbers
rational numbers irrational numbers and
honored or not they're all real numbers
so in some sense this is just all the
numbers you've ever heard of because
they're going to use a talk about this
phrase a lot and used it in our notation
and we're introducing you simple it's an
R with the phase e double light on it
ball this is a symbol for real real a D
capital are real it's a special name
okay so anytime you see me use that
symbol I mean the real numbers thank you
so what are these things are these
functions well make it a little
subheading onomichi which is relations
and function
think back to the start of you begin
arithmetic and algebra there are three
kinds of algebraic objects that you have
encountered in the course already I'll
give you a clues in order of complexity
they start with E and E and five what
are it remember algebraic objects so
again I think the claim is that he said
I know I heard you said nothing up there
by 100 K equations equality is just
another name for equations okay either
in equality I just sort of like a
specialized version of the original good
there are other things that is quite
different I did okay we looked at these
and then up top expression very good
okay so and expression is simply when
you've got other activities took them
together it is in a heap write an
equation is where you have a pair of
expression that you do what you you say
that they are equal right or
alternatively if you want to talk about
is positive you say they are not equal
in this particular way one's bigger than
the other ones bigger than or equal to
the other gears Yeji
what was the difference with an identity
it means it's an equation that is true
for all values of whatever you've got in
there
right so if X plus five equals three is
true sometimes for a very specific value
of x okay but someone can't give me an
example of an algebraic identity
I play BP's into your head give you
several okay so you make sure a
triggerfish upon that I hear a case
you're done on they'll do okay so this
be also an equation but inaudible
equation it's always true no matter what
value of did you put into it we're going
to talk about functions and relations
today so what I want to do is sort of
take these objects yurina and so I'm
going to zoom into them because there's
this sort of nested definition that
we've got so I want you to put circle
around equations inclusions because this
idea of relations is very closely
connected to crazy
dispatch relations look just like
equations they look just like equation
but there are little bit different so
let me give you some qualifying status
relations they're not just any kind of
equation they're an equation where
you've got two variables or to produce
so you can quite easily come up with an
equation that has any number of premiere
rules that you want X plus y plus 10
plus TV plus whatever equals whatever
you want okay as actual equation that's
fine but a relation is limited to two
right so usually these are things like
say X&Y
this is the kind of pair of printer
you'll see 99 cent of the time but does
it have to be your carrier variables or
integrals could be anything you like
I'll give you another common example
which will come to a little bit later in
the course
tired and position oops look my finish
that yet so for example time is a
variable it's something that can change
we might indicate with our teeth correct
position is also something that can
change and we will pair these up in a
relation where they're related together
right time position how about something
like say altitude and temperature now I
pick these pairs very deliberately right
altitude at temperature for example
excuse me are two variables that are not
like completely freedom they are related
to each other it connected which is why
we call them relations okay and we can
state that relation with and equation so
two variables are integrals as an
example out from here the like I said
we've been dealing with this for a long
time here I'm about to write our
relation between x and y it's not my
favorite I use it all the time
this looks just like an equation you've
seen before but do you see how it fits
what we're talking about right you've
got two variables and it indicates that
there's a relationship between x and y
if you know something about X then you
lose something about Y as well it's
effective or if you do what altitude
where you would know something about
your temperature as well and or normal
so this is that idea of connection okay
is not to occur in addition to having a
very fixed number of variables right you
can't solve a relationship like you can
solve an equation right in fact that's
the main thing you do when you see the
equation you like but I can find out
whatever value satisfies that the
meaning you can't solve a relation is
because almost certainly in fact this is
the reason why
design a relation we usually have an
infinite number of solutions there's not
just one right so you can't solve a
relation there's a whole range of
different values that can you can put
into this straight
so underneath this there are multiple
solutions and because if you've got two
variables in here for example x and y we
talked about the things that solved that
things that could possibly solve your
relation in terms of your X's and you're
wise so the possible X values that lead
to a solution for your relation the
possible X values we call that is
amazing right the possible x rays they
can lead to a solution for your relation
we call that the domain and the possible
Y values that could lead to a solution
you've heard of this one report we
called the range domain and range domain
and range it's pretty easy to remember
which ones which because just like x and
y domain and range are alphabetical so
that might be a helpful cue for you X Y
D are okay so before we move any further
just think about this relation I've
already written up here okay this is a
bit boring that domain
what possible X values in here will lead
to a solution and the answer in this
case is 80 x value you like any x values
in your life right I can put an x value
in here and a Y value will pop out right
that's fine okay so this domain here is
will anything but what you have look at
the range the range is not anything for
example if I try let's try y equals
negative one if you put negative one in
here and then you try and solve this you
can't find a solution you'll look at
your finger can't factor out you tried
with square use the quadratic formula
just blows up in your face right you
actually do get solutions they're just
not real solutions
we'll come to another time my point is
you can't just put in any number you
like I happen to go off the top of my
head if I'm remembering this correctly
I bet the range here is y is greater
than or equal to negative 1/4 I think
you can go wrap that and you can tell me
if that's true yes what it corresponds
to is is gram here if you were to go can
you picture what it looks like whether
it's at a negative 2 and negative 3
because when you factor either it's just
X 2 X plus 3 and you've got a
y-intercept right there so can you
picture where that is sort of shift over
mostly in the second quadrant the second
quadrant over there where does it dip
down to and the answer is if my memory
is right that's where it dips down to
and then it doesn't go any further okay
so what we described is you can think
about this domain or major here in two
different ways but colliculi the one
i've been appealing to visually where is
the graph go or where did the graph
exist is maybe a better word aprender
where does the graph exist that will
tell you the domain and range and this
is what tells you why the domain for
this is all the values because the
parabola never stops doesn't it never
hits a brick wall so that can't go any
further
it just goes forever and ever never
where does the glass exist a more
technical way to say it is where is the
relation another the capital is because
such an important word be fine
okay so we would say this relation is
defined for all values of X the only one
is defined for are the Y values of valve
or equal to negative 1/4
okay now this is such an important idea
we haven't even got to functions yet but
we need to sort of wrap our heads around
what this looks like